welcome to this video playing em-50 what
is this vladimir smirnov p.m. vladimir
simonov from australia he sounds like a
old-time australian um let's see
may I can do father Blumenfeld again
many players however don't even play d5
here they didn't want to be known him
but oops so he took it is it d5 actually
is six mm-hmm okay let's start with d5
so how exactly do you play this but
should be 797 I don't know something
like that probably I really don't know
this opening and in much detail but it
comes really naturally what black should
do yeah I think I somehow omitted a6 at
the right moment this this looks a bit a
bit uncomfortable on I'd say
uncomfortable is the wrong word but what
I have saw what I said what I saw about
this opening in games didn't look like
this normally okay let's let's get ahead
here I need to do something in the
center cannot sit and wait Eid does not
cancel probably for good reason
yeah but a thought before I can you can
give it a check 95 but this is not not
really great for white I will have
pushing you for at the end oh really
you have it but this is just this is
just excellent for black I get an e4 III
year
95 is probably the point and on III
maybe he can play castles maybe can play
castle on salmon if not hissed is just
exploding or imploding or whatever what
I mean is lots of body parts flying
around in the air III III castles
Queeny five is awesome it prevents
castles and enter threatened sea 396
there is Knight takes d5 which is okay
or III even even then okay I need to I
need to lose at some point so let's yeah
that's very quickly played as usual and
now III am III and then f4 don't know
let's let's do this
you can play a forward Queeny form isn't
this quite good if he takes you know if
he takes the eight I mean are you
threatened on g2 and I think but Queen
f3 probably now I really did these
points are enough compensation I can
easily give up give up the exchange it
does not matter really okay mmm so what
now just take on d5 maybe intending
Knight c3 yeah this should be quite good
takes Bishop takes Queen takes Knight f8
there's Bishop b3 and at the end this is
this is a bit a bit annoying okay so I
just can't play a move like that
preparing things here the idea is 95
Bishop d5 Queen d5 Knight f8 e 2 yeah so
and and then what is white moving here I
don't I don't really see him at a great
move even Queen f3 I can I can't play
Queen c2 for example but the pawns are
just very strong it probably needs to
sacrifice a piece to get rid of the porn
somehow
hmm yeah I know it's tough to play here
for what came interesting I can now Wow
- is this nonsense real that's just
recapture I need to keep the pawns here
as long as I keep those pawns I have an
excellent compensation ok Queen c2 was
my intention here and I think it's fine
my next move can easily be 96 attacking
her form okay Roxy one maybe okay okay
I'm getting low on time maybe this
wasn't the brightest idea going to see -
you should be a - Bishop III I didn't
really see I mean it still looks good
but I didn't didn't really appreciate
the whole idea
yeah come on this this is going to win
right I didn't see that move okay
it just just looks like a super
dangerous attack here
okay can also check here then getting
the night to f2 or something night f2 is
unfortunately my morning Jeff yeah I
don't have enough time to him sorry to
calculate this to the end rhenium
tonight h2 and don't really have
something great I can give this I can't
give the check iam he cannot take
because of queen h5 made aha so queen e5
what would have been interesting
check no I can just check him kingi one
down it's not clear what my next move is
okay check check again and think about
this again checking here now yeah why
not check then taking with the night or
with the Queen it's both for Trillium or
something else e 2 is going to be very
tough to meet
only nine seconds left
oh there is a big ring he made check on
what yeah I was terribly slow but what
the heck
he was just pre moving here some
nonsense and I was I was I wasn't really
aware that I was so low on time so while
losing this is a bit a bit weird check
also it was a pretty one-sided game
actually I assumed I simply didn't
realize that I was so down on the clock
and a bit I relaxed too early him
because well this is just like a minus
ten or something this position Oh minus
13
okay yeah a tough tough to analyze I
mean it was just so murky however think
about what he did here playing efore and
this this is just she just totally crazy
it's very obviously good for black the
question is if I evening played it in
the right and the right way
this is maybe even better this is maybe
even better because here he had does not
have even 95m something this is like an
immediate loss it's probably that's
probably even stronger when Bishop takes
this is good for black but it's not
winning outright compass on - to know
which is quite ok but the other other
line is probably winning winning
completely and here it is just very very
murky very tough to - same in a
practical game why this is very
difficult to play maybe the computer the
computer actually
YTM but this is some very theoretical
thing yeah here black is already winning
again and just yeah and this is this
attack I don't know if it was correct
but it it is not practically projected
just winning check check
yeah it's him yeah I just I just I just
froze a bit earlier no wine I'm still so
very early yeah but though I should have
should have won that he was just playing
playing some pre moves chatter I won't
start about this increment thing again
which makes those games totally
impossible okay
thanks for watching